- Hello.
Hello you all.
Welcome to this presentation.
I'm going to be talking
about the AI offering
that we have at Heroku.
Before we start, I'm
going to introduce myself.
My name is Julian Duque.
I'm the principal developer
advocate for Heroku,
which is a Salesforce company.
And being a Salesforce company,
we are publicly traded company,
so please don't make
any purchase decisions
based out of things that are
not yet publicly available.
I might be mentioning things
that are not yet fully GA.
So Heroku is a platform as a service.
We have been in business since 2010, 2011.
We were the first platform as a service
for Ruby on Rails applications
and now we support more than
nine programming languages
and some other managed services.
We are renowned for offering
a great developer experience
and our developer experience is that good
that a lot of companies,
open source products
have created the Heroku of X.
They try to mimic our experience
and create something out of what we do.
So a couple years ago we asked
ourselves these questions.
Who is going to build the Heroku of AI?
Who is going to bring
the developer experience
of building AI applications
that offers Heroku?
And of course the answer was ourselves.
We are going to be
building the Heroku of AI.
So basically building AI applications
and agents is challenging.
You'll need to make a lot of decisions
and take care of things
that are not usually
pretty much obvious.
For example, we need to
select the right models,
the large language models
we are going to be using
for our application.
If it is like a text-to-text
model, emails generation model,
if we are going to do
embeddings, we need to make sure
that we are using the
right model for our app.
Also, how are we going to integrate
with the other applications and services?
How are we going to allow the LLM
or the model to access data securely
'cause right now one of the risks
about building AI application
is that data leakage.
We are giving access to
our data to a third party
that can access that it
might be like vulnerable
to certain security issues.
And also how are we going to operate
the infrastructure behind AI?
Like a lot of hidden
things that we don't know,
like managing GPUs, being able to maintain
the models running.
There is a lot of complexity behind.
Also, it's hard to make
things easy for developers,
easy for the company
to operate and manage.
Heroku has been working
in a platform for a while,
so we already have an integrated
platform where you can use
and deploy your applications and agents.
We have great developer experience
and operational experience.
We already selected a
list of curated AI models
that we know are used in the industry
and that are working for these
new type of applications.
And we also added extensibility
through the model context
protocol, which is this protocol
that allows the LLMs to
have access to more context
through prompt resources and tools
and getting to production is hard.
We need to make a lot of
decisions that are complex.
For example, when we want to
take an application on an agent
to production, we need to
choose where are we going
to deploy this application?
What is going to be the
underlying operating system
and the working configuration
that we will use for our app?
How is the CPU and memory
going to be distributed
for our application?
What is going to be the
data store, the logging,
the observability?
So there is a lot of moving
pieces that are related
to deploying an application to production.
With Heroku we simplify all of this choice
and we are giving you
an opinionated platform
so you can focus on
building the application
using our developer tools to deploy
and then operating your application
by using the tools we are
giving you to scale your app,
to monitor your app,
to do the observability
and we take care of the rest,
we take care of the observability,
we take care of the metric,
we take care of the support,
and we give you the tools for you to scale
and maintain the application.
And this is increasing
developer productivity.
This is reducing the money
that you are spending on DevOps
and infrastructure operation
and it is increasing
the return of investment
of your application.
So lemme tell you about
the different AI offerings
that we announced and released this year
and this is why we became
the AI platform as a service.
First we have managed
inference and agents.
So we allow you to provision
AI models to an app
just with one click or with one command.
You can select from a
list of curated AI models
that allows you to do text
generation, image generation
or embeddings with just one click.
This is something that
is available right now.
We recently launched support
for Claude 4.5 Sonnet,
for Claude 4.5 Haiku, Amazon Nova Lite
Amazon Nova Pro, gpt-oss-120b.
We also added support for MCP,
the model context protocol
and this support this in two ways.
We have an Heroku MCP server
that allows developers
and DevOps people to use our MCP
that knows how to manage Heroku resources.
So this is for builders
but we also have a platform for you
to securely deploy MCP
servers that you are building.
So you can deploy and
host your MCP on Heroku
and access that MCP remotely
through an HTTP interface
or directly from within the
agent endpoint that we give you
with the managed inference and agents.
We also have support for vector
database through pgvector,
which is an extension of PostgreSQL
to create vector databases
to perform similarity search
and create retrieval augmented
generation pipelines.
And we also, back in October
we released the pilot
of Heroku Vibes which is a
tool that that allows you
to build web applications
using natural language
from the web.
And this tool lets you build the app
and deploy the app automatically Heroku.
So you don't even need to worry about
the infrastructure behind we
are taking care of everything
and just with one prompt
and a couple of adjustments
if you want to iterate over it,
you can have an application from an idea
to production in minutes.
Let me show you a couple
of demos that I have here
that shows you first the Heroku
manage inference and agents
and how I built an application
that uses our Heroku AI
to get access to data
and to be able to perform smart actions
within an application.
And another example of Heroku Vibes
which can let you build
applications using natural language.
Cool.
So I built this application
which is a dashboard
for a solar energy company.
Let's say you have a solar
insulation in your house
or in your business
and you want to monitor
how much energy are you producing,
how much energy are you consuming,
what are going to be your savings
and get some insights
about the application.
So this dashboard already gone
and access my PostgreSQL database
that is deployed on Heroku
and creates the dashboard.
But this is your typical web application.
I want to also ask questions using AI
to get access to insights from my data.
So how can I do this?
Usually people build
retrieval augmented generation pipelines.
So you get data from the
database, you pass that data
to the inference model
and then you perform some
inference on top of that data.
What we did here is that
we are using agents,
we have an agent using the
Heroku endpoint and tools.
Tools that we maintain,
which are pretty much MCPs
that are hosted and brought in on Heroku
to give my agent access to the database.
I am not giving my database credentials,
I am just giving a read
only access to a follower
of my database so I can
safely retrieve data
and analyze that data.
So let me open the agent here.
I already have two queries that I did,
but I'm going to be doing
something here live.
The first one I ask about
what was my lowest
production date this month.
So I want to know from all
this month what was the date
that I had the lowest production.
So it is performing a tool execution,
which is the database query.
It's generating this query.
So my agent already knows
the shape of my database,
but we also have tools
to retrieve the schema
of the database so it doesn't hallucinate
the shape of your data.
It's generating the query,
it's running the query
and giving me the response
and then the inference is
taking care of the answer.
So pretty much we are feeding the context
of my prompt with tools.
For the other question I want to chart
or to create an image
of the hourly production data of today.
So it's gonna be pretty much the same.
I need to go to the database
but then how can I create that image?
So for that I'm using another
tool which is code execution.
In this case I'm using Python
and the Python dependencies
to generate images
like matplotlib, pandas, numpy, et cetera
to create the image on the fly.
And I'm uploading this image to Amazon S3
and then returning a predesigned URL.
So we can see here that we
have the database query.
This is fetching the data
hour by hour of today
and then it's passing that data
to a Python execution tool.
Since you can run any
application on Heroku,
what we are doing here is
we are generating this code.
The LLM is generating this code.
It is spinning a dine on
Heroku a built-on machine
running the code sandbox salesly on Heroku
and getting the return.
So you are just only consuming the seconds
that that application was running.
I get the return which
is the pre-signed URL
on Amazon S3 and now I have
the answer which is the report
and the analysis.
So let me trigger another prompt here.
So what was the peak production
in the past seven days?
So the same, I need to use
a tool to get this data.
In this case I am expecting that my agent
that I configured is going
to perform a database query,
getting that data from the database
and then doing an analysis over that data.
So this is the query, it failed.
Amazing.
So now it is trying another query.
Now we got the response.
So you saw that it has like
a self-healing capability
and this is not a scripted,
this is a live demo.
It failed and now it got the data
and created the report that
I just asked on the fly.
So how this work, how
I provision this model
to my application?
So this is an application
that is deployed on Heroku.
It's an OJS application,
an API that access the Heroku AI services.
So how can I provision this AI services?
As any other service on Heroku.
I am on the Heroku dashboard,
I'm on the resources
and I will search for Heroku
manage inference and agents.
It'll provide a list of the
supported models that we have.
I can select the model.
Let's say we want Claude 4.5.
I click on the order form, provision,
and now I have the model
available to my application.
How can I access from my
application to that model?
Basically this is giving me
an API URL and an API key.
And now I can use an SDK
or directly performing an HTTP request
to the inference endpoint
and get the response.
This is everything working
on Heroku infrastructure.
So your data is not going
out to a third party,
everything is within
the same infrastructure
is staying safe and is trusted
getting access to the database.
If I go to the settings of my application,
I reveal the configuration variables.
You might see here the different API keys
and API URLs for the
models I have provisioned.
So what I have to do on my
app, I will show you the code.
This is my agent.
I have a system prompt,
in the system prompt
that I just specifying
this is what you do.
You are a solar energy agent.
This is the type of tools and
libraries you have access to.
As I mentioned, I'm giving
access to the library to upload
to S3 to do matplotlib and
the charting on Python.
I'm specifying everything here
being very, very specific.
And after defining the
prompt and the tools,
you can see we have Heroku tools.
So these are tools that runs on Heroku,
not tools that I have to write.
I'm giving access to the
database to those tools.
And then what I'm doing
is an HTTP request, just call it an API
and I'm using the same OpenAI API shape.
So if you are using an SDK
that talks that specific API
like for example LangChain
or the Vercel AI SDK
or Pydantic, LlamaIndex.
Depending on the technology
of your choice to agents
you can use Heroku AI for that.
So now let me switch to the other AI tool
that we are offering our people.
This is more like pro
development for developers,
for builders that can use the services.
This other is more for business user,
people that is not a
hundred percent technical
that they want to also build applications
and deploy to Heroku
which is Heroku Vibes.
So here on Heroku Vibes
I start from a prompt.
I need to define the
prompt of the application
that I want this to build.
So for this example,
I'm going to be building
an agenda builder for AWS re:Invent 2025.
So I'm asking create this
agenda builder application.
So I want to track my sessions,
store the information on local storage,
but I can also store it on a
PostgreSQL database on Heroku.
It will take care of the backend.
And I'm giving a data source,
get the data from this CSV
that lives on the internet
and now I'm going to
create that application.
So there are like a couple of things
that are going to happen here.
First it's going to enter into plan mode.
It's going to create a
plan, a step by step plan
of how the agent is going
to build this application.
You can approve the plan
or suggest changes to that plan
and once you have that plan approved,
it's going to start building.
Since I just have two
minutes in my presentation,
I'm going to show you exactly this prompt
and the whole process and
a couple of iterations
that I did changing this
prompt and the final result.
So here you can see that I
have like a long conversation
with the agent but it decided
with the same exact prompt.
I want my agenda builder,
this is how I want it.
This is where you are going
to be storing the data
and this is where you
are getting the data.
It provides a plan, I approve the plan
and then it went and
implement the application.
And since we are using Heroku here,
it is deploying application
directly to Heroku.
So the application that I
have here is the final result
is leaving on Heroku.
You can see the Heroku app domain.
It is live and I can just use it.
I can just add sessions to my agenda,
go check the agenda.
And that's exactly what I asked for.
I then asked for some changes.
For example, I want to have
like dark and light theme
or I want to change this color
to be something different
or I want you to have like a backend
and I sort information
on a PostgreSQL database.
And that's the iterative
process that you are going to do
with these AI tools to
build an application
and take it live just using a prompt
and going to production.
So that's what Heroku has for you.
One, which is the Heroku
AI services for you
to build custom agents, deploy them on.
And then we are giving you also a tool
for building applications using AI
that simplifies that process.
That's pretty much it.
Thank you so much.
If you have any questions, we
are located at the booth 838,
just right next by the Salesforce booth.
You can go there, visit us,
ask more about what we have
for you to build AI applications
and other type of applications.
And also you can like please
complete the session survey
on your mobile application.
And thank you so much for coming.